mais moi j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour
vous deux mois après la mise en vigueur
de la loi alimentation une première
étude vient établir que l'augmentation
des prix aurait principalement touché à
l'alcool
un sujet du cisr infos de france des
dans les rayons des supermarchés des
prix de l'alcool en hausse depuis
plusieurs semaines + 3 % en moyenne et
pour certaines catégories d'alcool c'est
même plus il faut compter +5 3% pour les
mousseux +7 3% pour les bières plus 8,8
pour cent pour les jeans à l'origine de
ces hausses l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi alimentation le 1er février dernier
qui impose au distributeur de réaliser
une marge de 10% minimum sur l'ensemble
des produits alimentaires alors que
cette loi n'a rien changé pour les
produits sur lesquels la grande
distribution faisait déjà de fortes
marges
elle a eu un impact sur l'alcool un
produit où les marges étaient
traditionnellement plus faible alors
c'est un produit donc où les marges
étaient traditionnellement plus faible
or là on voit des augmentations ont
assez impressionnante à les reconnaître
en deux mois pour les jeans mot
évidemment on voit pas de jeans tous les
jours mais bon tu m'aimes plus bien que
lui pour cent leurs hommes +8 6% la
bière si chère au coeur des milli lopez
+7 3%
je rappelle quand même que l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé que
celles à consommer avec modération bien
évidemment mais est ce que vous
comprenez vous pourquoi les ce prix
d'alcool et le fait que ça augmente et
est ce que vous trouvez ça bien
finalement bah non il y passa bien je
suis désolé ben oui parce qu'encore une
fois et vous avez passez moi
l'expression mais c'est encore le
consommateur qui va trinquer
pourquoi pas dans les jolis être un poil
à brac les jeux de mots c'est encore
consommateurs qui se fait avoir c'est
encore le consommateur qui voit les prix
augmenter sur des produits qui du titre
alors bien évidemment sont pas d'arriver
le premier cas c'est pas des produits
première nécessité sauf que si jamais
effectivement toutes ses marges étaient
reversés aux producteurs et tout ça je
dirais bomba why not c'était le but à
l'origine de la loi alimentation
jusqu'au rien dans cette loi ne les
oblige à reverser aux producteurs donc
ça veut dire on va mettre plus d'argent
dans les poches des mecs qui en ont déjà
plein donc ça m'énerve car les dosettes
à daggar jeu et en plus je ne crois pas
j'avais su que ce qui t'énerve c'est
surtout ce soit devenu un petit peu plus
cher moi je trouve que cette loi elle
est ignoble mais que tout le coup pour
le coup c'est très très bien que
l'alcool soit en augmentation c'est le
seul truc qui sera dissuasif qui
permettra aux gens de moins consommer
d'alcool et emilie mon chat etc c'est
que tu adores mais tu ne peux pas
être dans un discours où tu passes ton
temps à dire que l'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé
qui faut le consommer avec modération et
tu as raison et notamment sur la route
etc et en même temps et en même temps te
plaindre d'une augmentation qui tu le
sais très bien et la seule raison
valable pour arrêter un petit peu la
consommation d'alcool en france
il est vrai que par exemple le paquet
cigarettes donc compter bien sûr mais
quand comme héros enfin comme tout si on
augmentait les prix de tous évidemment
on en consommeraient moins c'est
mathématique c'est logique donc après
cette loi je la trouve très injuste pour
le consommateur mais que le seul sur un
certain général vous gêne franchement
sur l'alcool jamais j'ai bien ce qu'en
fait j'ai très bien on a l'impression en
tentant de recruter plus naïve que je ne
le suis d'habitude et dieu sait si je
suis naïve
on a l'impression que ça ils l'ont fait
dans l'intérêt des gens c'est pas du
tout ça et c'est ça qui m'énerve
attention à la ligne on met une taxe
supplémentaire parce qu'on se dit
qu'effectivement l'alcool ça tue et qui
veut faire quelque chose là je dirais ok
discutons-en là pas du tout là c'est
juste pour voilà se faire encore plus de
tune sur le dos des gens savent que les
gens et ce comme caroline vous dit elle
vous dit finalement peu importe
l'intention le résultat est là et ça va
donc de fait faire diminuer la
consommation des foyers qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent et qui veulent se
faire un apéro de temps en temps avec
leurs pattes
eh ben ils peuvent plus donc ils font
quoi maintenant ils ont plus aucune
distraction ils sont obligés comme je te
couper un bras pour aller acheter une
bouteille de gin qui m'amuse beaucoup
aussi petite parenthèse c'est que comme
par hasard le seul truc qui ne manquent
pas c'est le champagne parce que de
toute façon
voilà c'était déjà super héros et ils se
disent si c'est encore plus haut plus
personne n'achète champagne donc pas la
fin mais jimmy qu'est ce que vous pensez
de des arguments de vos deux camarades
qui visiblement ne sont absolument pas
d'accord non mais sont très mauvais les
arguments des mini et je rejoins bien
sûr caroline parce que lorsque tu dis un
apéro de temps en temps si ça n'a perron
de temps en temps vous ne sentirez pas
cette augmentation de 5%
parce que de temps en temps vous allez
voir en revanche qu'ils avaient une
consommation régulière
là vous êtes capables ça va impacter
faut pas oublier que l'alcool première
cause de mortalité avec les vitesses
alors ça dépend comment quand on veut
mettre un peu de radars on dit que c'est
la vitesse mons et globalement c'est la
vitesse et l'alcool
cinquante mille décès directs liés à
l'alcool et indirects donc je pense
qu'il faut aller taper encore un peu
plus fort et moi ce qui m'étonne dans
l'histoire c'est pourquoi ce qu'on dit
que traditionnellement les marges
étaient plus faibles
le scandale il est là pourquoi les
supermarchés des bandas pour l'alcool on
va faire mal par contre sur les couches
on va y aller on va mettre des taxes sur
la pâte à tartiner là on va y aller donc
le scandale il est là et je pense qu'il
faut aller au delà ton quand emilie vous
10/06 avait été fait de façon ouverte en
disant on veut réduire la consommation
d'alcool donc comme on l'a fait pour la
cigarette et donc ont vertement on dit
qu'on augmente parce que c'est un
problème de santé publique et que la vie
finalement c'est un effet au cachet
pervers qu'est ce que vous en pensez
schéma est mauvais mais peu importe si
on fermait l on a moins le consommateur
- pathologies mon addiction
eh ben je dis tant mieux d'accord je
vous le dirai mais les macs ont vaincu
away al'inverse caroline et jimmy eux
nous font entrer dans une vie à une
société un état qui nous prive de
liberté qui nous empêche un peu de faire
la fête et surtout encore une fois
qu'ils engraissent les multinationales
les supermarchés ce sont eux la qui donc
répercutent cette hausse avec cette loi
de l'alimentation et loyal à rézé
s'était pas fait pour engraisser
justement les voilà j'ai appris et là
c'est nous qui payons est à nouveau
pourquoi pour les toutes petites joies
du quotidien
je ne parle pas en effet de boire tous
les jours mais juste d'avoir ces petits
moments de plaisir et là on nous les
enlève d'accord et vous pensez que ça va
mais mais mais le fait que ça impacte
justement les consommations régulières
et que peut-être ça fera baisser mais
bien sûr que non valait bien sûr les
croyants sont ceux qui pour sa commande
en même temps juste quelque chose
dissuasive notamment lorsqu'on parle du
prix du paquet de cigarettes c'est
d'augmenter le prix donc c'est une chose
pour l'alcool plus ça coûte cher
- aura des jeunes parce que les petits
jeunes de 15 4 15 16 ans qui ont pas
beaucoup d'argent qui vont mettre un peu
d'argent de la bière parce que ça coûte
pas cher mais si ça coûte plus cher à
guingamp - boire à battre tant mieux
parce que je suis designer fumeurs
fument toujours autant donc nous mater
depuis mon roman on a poussé
c'est quand même génial on a posé la
question à nos téléspectateurs loi
alimentation une augmentation des prix
concerne surtout l'alcool normal ou pas
normal normal à 61%
c'est pour ce coup là caroline et jamie
pourrions remporter la balade en tout
cas on comprend mieux pourquoi les prix
de l'alcool augmente
et voilà voilà tout c'est beau car ça
faisait longtemps qu est l élu c'était
la dernière séance complète très bien
trappe